歡迎回到趙花
艾倫說
我想要問艾倫
如果讓你重新選擇一次職業
你會選什麼呢
可以選那種
譬如說郭台銘的兒子
不是職業
不是選投胎
這樣不是職業
兒子這個身分
不是
好好好
我選什麼
我希望可以不要被管的職業
現在也沒人管你
所以就可能還是會是
以這個方向出發
對對對對
不要管我這樣子
對對對
叛逆的個性是不是
但是我們今天的大來賓
很厉害喔
他其实有机会
或是他当过人人称县的半导体工程师
要是到现在可能分红一年都几个亿了
可是他却选择当分析师
到底哪里想不开呢
我们先来欢迎他
就是不会投顾的我们的半导体分析师
黎智健 Vic
哈喽大家好
我是Vic
很花俏耶
那他没办法当工程师
但是很花俏没关系
因为Vic有一个座右铭
花落盛開 蝴蝶自來
對 這個剛才有人講
這個如果是蒼蠅的話
代表這個花不是很好的花
可是以前就看到這句話
你們應該有聽過對不對
因為我發現
就是當這個做得很好
不管在各行各業做得很好
然後身邊呢
就會有很多資源
開始往他靠近
有沒有發現
那個很成功的人
不用請客
別人都請他
明明他口袋錢最多
是
然後再來就是
如果衍生出來的話
但我們期許自己
能夠變成一個盛開的花
對不對 現在還在還在含苞待放
然後但是呢
如果
欸 引用到股市也可以
是
是不是
這個有些好的公司啊
它其實盛開的時候
就發現資金開始湧出
然後一天成交量幾十萬張
可是在這個很多新聞啊
消息還沒出來之前
它的基本面
還沒被大家看到的時候
欸 罰人問津
我覺得都一樣的道理
好 Vic 的意思是
因為它是一朵美麗的花
所以它愛開在哪裡
蝴蝶都會來找他
我希望未來有機會
不是蒼蠅
但是還是要問了
因為這兩個行業應該都不錯
但是半導體工程師
可能大家會更有感覺啊
分紅啊
配股 股價都上千元啊
為什麼不繼續當工程師
要來當產業分析師
其實我覺得跟艾倫講是一樣
不想要被管
這個
當到後面
當著人家都說
這個做得高不如做得穩
領得多不如領得久
所以當到這個高階主管之後
我發現這個壓力其實真的是
不成比例的變大
然後也不太想說
受制在這個體系裡面
那反而發現了另一個興趣
就投資
大家其實都有投資的興趣
每個人都想要在辦公室
那個廁所裡
都會有投資的興趣
但是我發現我那個興趣是很濃厚的
我在這個出差的飛機上面
我不是在看公司的報告
我都在看那個線圖
所以你的薪水小偷
對啊 薪水小偷
出差的飛機上
那時間是我的
然後所以就會想說
那未來我要當一個分析師
然後就剛好有機會
就是因為認識了老王
然後他也在
他說你有產業的經驗
那過去的分析師
其實大部分都是
財經背景 金融背景
那你是產業出來的
而且你從底下的
這個產品工程師
一直到行銷
一直到這個策略
那你都知道
那你原始來這邊
有一個發揮的地方
然後我就覺得還不錯
所以我就去考分析師
所以我覺得不錯
是因為你念的是理工科對不對
理工科出來的話
你先選擇進產業
再進來當分析師
可是如果你念的是商學相關的
就不一定能進去當半導體工程師了
是啊
其實我是不務正業
當初也有去面試排輯店
如果面試排輯店
現在就不會有FIC了
你就會待在那裡是不是
我就待在那裡了
我前幾天才一個學長
才密火
他說
你是XXX老師的學生嗎
我是你學長
然後我說學長好你在哪裡
他說他在台積電17年
是
哇這個
我覺得如果我再繼續在那邊的話
應該也是不錯的啦
喔那你可以把學長挖過來當產業分析師啊
對搞不好
學長現在人家成就很好的
是我們要現在跟他看齊
但是我覺得很厲害的一點是
因為Vic真的待過產業
所以目前你可以分辨的出來
現在大家都在長嘛
因為AI時代
我們台灣得天獨厚
幾乎每一個領域都說跟 AI 有關
可是漲到這裡
你覺得誰是被低估的
當然誰可能已經 price in 了
其實我覺得百花齊放
就很多產業
它都在成長中
都在缺料中
技術都在進步中
那但是有些股價已經在反應中
那我覺得目前仍然是合理的
像最近的這個先進封裝
封裝相關的族群
那算是合理
另外 CCL ABF
還有 MLCC
因為做了一個比較大的修正
所以反而在合理的區間內
但是啊 最近有一些
大家常常就是念的出口的一些專有名詞
以前都不認識的
比如說 CPO啦
FOP、OP啦
玻璃基板、TGB
那這種反而很難評估
所以你不能說它是合理還是不合理
有的已經反應很合理超過了
但有的還是不合理
因為它未來的這個成長
它是有這種翻倍的機會
所以有些很難評估
再來呢 我覺得有些是被低估
你明明看到它未來成長性很高
或是說甚至連八月份
繳出來成績單都是很好的
可是呢就是不反應
就是不反應
像是電力啊或是像產物工程
明明在手訂單這麼多
合約負債這麼高
可是股價就是相對疲弱
但是未來還是看得見
好這個可能要有信念
因為我們常常講
會不會股價不漲就是它背後的問題
但你覺得這個產業真的沒問題
對啊因為
AI是在泡沫之前
不管泡沫還是泡沫之後
它的這個 input
always是電力嘛
那電力進來以後才有 output 才有 token
不管在訓練的時候
還是在推論的時候都需要很多的電力
我們從很多報告可以看出來
目前 AI 的電力荒
從明年開始有非常大的缺口
一直不斷產生
那有哪些缺口
我可以自己 Q 下一頁
好 因為今天 MEC 準備的資料非常多
對 我們翻譯的速度比翻臉還快
這個大家會很擔心
因為很多雜音
包含 AI 要放緩速度
或是說地方政府開始叫
這些 AI Data Center 賣一點蓋
或是不給你核准權
但是實際上影響並不高
我們實際上去看
它到底影響多少
數字能夠說話
譬如說 300 個地方政府
實際上只有影響 2.3 Gigawatt
2.3 到底是多還是少
我不知道對不對
可是我們看到明年
有 38 Gigawatt
是兩倍在成長中
而且這是核准的
可以繼續走的所以比例上一看大家就知道其實影響並不大對不對進行中的而且很多啊透過他們 BTM 的部分就是 Behind the Meter
他們自己可以自備電力
自己去產生電
所以會跟像 BE 這種公司合作
更快的可以產生出電給 Data Center 用
那這種情況下核准機率又變高了
再加上有些只是暫緩而已
可能三四個月之後他又合可了嘛
對不對 因為這種競賽大家不能落後
那我們可以看到機櫃的數量
持續在翻倍中
而且價格
就是它的含金量也越來越高
那這個部分就大家不要太疑慮
未來還是持續在電力上有很大的需求
地方政府會這樣限制
也是因為他們覺得電力或基礎設施來不及是不是
對 沒有錯
因為很多的這個 data center
其實受惠的還是 CSP 業者
對於一般居民
哇 這些電力設施在我隔壁
我才不要 我賺不到錢
這不是台灣很容易發生
美國地不是很大嗎
對啊 不然就免費
GEMANite 給人家用嘛 對不對
這種基本上公關要做好
那這樣子就會很快就合可
可是從這個瓦特到幾個瓦
其實為什麼
因為每個 GPU 它使用的電量越來越高
從過去 40 到 50 K 瓦
然後一直到整個機櫃現在可能上看 750 K 瓦這樣子
那需要的電力越高
它就去對於伺服器的電源的燙
就是整個市場需求
成長率你知道高達多少嗎
我看一下數字我嚇到
因為我過去常來理財商的秀
我們常常講說你看CaGR Cag
這35%值得注意
70%
好 70% 的成長
70% 成長
所以全球製造中心的電量需求量
你看超級高
那裡面會有一個到2030年有一個缺口
是268GbW
還記得上一頁我們說明年會有多少嗎
我們回顧一下
明年38
缺口268
你就知道了
這真的是缺口非常的大
那缺口這麼大的情況下
升電
然後電怎麼轉到這個 data center 裡面去轉換進去
然後到 data center 裡面怎麼轉換到這個 grid to chip
就是到 chip 端怎麼用到這個電
我覺得這裡面就產生很多的商機
因為它的缺口這麼大
所以要如火如荼的
增加這些基礎設施
沒錯
好
像這個大廠 Tranforce 就發布有電力缺口
再來呢
輝達的部分跟 Google 結盟
他們看Hupon影辦
趕快來做
電力的部分有問題
因為他們發現
過去像GPU在算力的部分
然後我們可能還在散熱的部分也很重視
發現電力也不行
要趕快來
所以Hupon影辦
像Google跟輝達結AEMA的聯盟
另外Amazon也入股
Jana AEC 公司
所以股價一天跳空30%
我覺得有點激勵這個族群的感覺
過來 Google 它也跟這個歐洲的芬蘭的公司
簽這個 150 億美元的 PPA
這是 Power Purchase Agreement
就是有一個 22 年的很長的一個採購合約
因為它在歐洲建 Data Center 一定要電
那這個核電的部分是它的選擇之一
如果它沒有保障好它的來電的話
它就沒有 Output 沒有 Token 可以用
那可是啊 就是跟不上 AI 的速度
美國技術電力設施其實
我們可以從幾個數據來看出來
剛才說到這個跳空30%
是
這個JANET AC
那除了它以外
其實我把這幾家
大家可以特別留意一下
觀察一下
最終一下這幾家
像這個Vertif
Eaton
或是GE
或是廣達
不是台灣的廣達
是美國的
或是Broom Energy
這幾家公司都有幾個狀況
比如說營收年增
然後創新高
然後再來是Q2調整之後
創高 裁測上修
然後再來在手訂單
創新高
再手定章很高 雙雙創高
再來這個首計破10億美元
由虧轉移
從這些跡象可以看得出來
這些公司雖然都在右下角
大家可以去看右下角
主要是因為過去的這個
4WP1還是相對比較高一點
所以做了一個修正
那修正完畢之後呢
看到未來實際上並沒有變
那花若盛開
蝴蝶自來
我覺得未來蝴蝶就會來
他們之前股價多多少少也強勢過
是
對 可是你看這一波
META大漲嘛
然后 AMD 创新高
Intel 也在大涨
对
那他们为什么
需求刚刚前面看了那么多
还没有办法轮到他们呢
诶
主要就是因为
过去的
那个我还提到的 PE 有点高
包含我们台湾的台大电
是
那过去他 PE 可能到了 40 倍以上
你会觉得不可思议
以前台大电呢
你怎么算怎么算
就 450 块就是紧绷了
那朋友问我说 450 块卖掉
就我爱卖掉就卖飞了
是
直接飙到 2500 块
可是到了2500塊
你再回頭去看的時候
當你看台牙店的4-World PE
你會怕到
你會覺得說
要休息一下
當你當初在看跌回來的旗紅
你會覺得
不會怕
因為4-World PE
你看到未來
就獲利就擺在那邊
你不會怕
所以我覺得這個部分
它的速度
就必須要讓時間去發酵
你要等它
就像小孩子長大
你不能在那邊很急
要不要助長
這個東西就是要時間
那待會我們看他們的今年的獲利跟明年獲利預估
你會覺得說還不錯
實際上更厲害的是後年的預估
是 因為 Vertif 或者是像 B1 會連到台灣什麼
齊鴻 高麗 他們都很厲害
對啊
鴻和台股這波比較厲害
對 上次來講電源講這個散熱
還有散熱沒事
接下來只好來講電源
來救救電源 你看看這一排
你看這一排 重電股
艾倫都沒在講
因為這不符合動能
這不行
這個右側交易者完全不行
你看
可是雖然不行
主要是因為過去他的本益比
因為他過去成長很高
大家用這種折旋估值一折回來
哇這個像這個華盛可能一千多塊
然後什麼的
但是
折旋是把未來都算進來
可是你發現說
他本益比就變相對比較高一點
他修正了很久
整理了很久
但是這些人你看他的訂單
AIDC的這個訂單
從121到200億
是不是衝高了
然後外銷比重也很高
也打進 Stargate
那另外像市電
再手訂單600億
能見度
這不是我寫的喔
我去找資料的
到29 30耶
是
可以講到這麼遠嗎
可以啊
明年的我覺得都有點變數
沒關係
至少人家是樂觀的
然後過來像中興電
過去也因為是軍工
它有一些
弊案的疑慮
很久了
所以嘛
你看在這裡面相對本益比
它就比較低一些些
那實際上人家還是有賺錢的
而且它是 GIS 的龍頭
在台灣裡面有很多這種
就是我們的伺服器中心裡面的像冷氣 電機超過應該七八成都是它在做的在手訂單也有默默的在耕耘不是沒做事雖然說股價很弱
但是人家還是有做事
能見度到2029
那其他像大同、東元
也是就是紛紛的開始轉換到
跟像META合作
或是跟資料中心合作
好 那這一組的話
本一比相對都很合理了
本來之前大家說滑成50倍
現在也默默的回到30幾倍了
對喔 是是是
所以在這裡面我覺得
最近有點整理
大家都不敢講的一檔股票
勇者來了
那這個中心電它第二進行收
稍微有激增了
16% 年增6%
有回來重點是毛利率
創進行新高
我覺得這代表產品組合做得還不錯
再來呢
今年也跨入AI Data Center裡面的一些
統包或是一些工程
中華電信跟四方在台灣
主要是它的客戶這樣子
加動率
加動率有100%以上
它驾动率这么高啊
120%
其实就是有点加班的意思
因为我们以前的驾动率大概就是
你差不多90% 80% 就很满了
如果你要再高一点点就是
可能把办公室拿来做
没有啦
就是加班然后办公室拿来做
比平常的这种这个产能
还要再高出一点
所以驾动率比较高
在资本支出小修
小修上修到15到21
代表人家还是有点企图心
那股价呢
这个要问艾伦了
看起來 感覺起來怎麼樣
下一頁
我本來想把包丟給他了
結果
不是 他不是快表態了
正上所有均線嗎
其實還不錯啊
就差放亮一根紅K
差一點亮
沒有亮啊
技術分析大師
對
是是是
觀察啦
我們都是觀察一下嘛對不對
那另外我們也可以看到
這個Pulse Supply Unit
它的佔比啊
有些人看到這個報告的時候
其實有點怕掉
會覺得說你看它的佔比
就是綠色那部分
這個嗎?綠色
是
你有沒有覺得笑到
14%到8%
是
到202627以上就開始8%
可是實際上是因為
GPU的價格越來越高
因為我們很少看到你會挑
那個佔比越來越小的來講
是是是是
是故意挑的
那原因是GPU的價格越來越高
加上
它GPU啊
它配套的措施
譬如說
一冷散熱
機櫃啦
這些都是變成說
它的 Power Supply Unit 的占比變少
可是要再附上這個
就是吃藥的時候要配水的意思一樣
你要知道
它的 Power Supply Unit 金額持續增加
而且是大幅增加
我們剛才說有一個 69% 很厲害了
我們這邊就看到一個巨怪
這個大物 120%
Cag 120%
也就是說它雖然的占比變少
但數量跟金額是這樣提升的
原因是因為它的含金量很高
從過去的 Harper 0.42 per watt 就是每一瓦
到了這個 VeroVit Arboron 它是 0.93 耶
這成了幾乎兩倍以上
所以相關的 這個整個 Pulse Part Unit 裡面
沒有那麼小 那麼長
這裡面有很多供應鏈 譬如說 PSU 的廠商
功率元件 磁性元件 電容散熱
因為也要散熱 這個功率也會高 它需要散熱
再來這個固態變壓器 電源 PMIC 控制 IC 都會受惠
因為這裡面的需求
規格技術提升
所以這些人都有機會
隨著技術提升
然後他的含金量就增加
不過電源供應器廠商
大廠小廠很多
然後供應元件的話
等一下也會聊
6月的時候說什麼
市場上都買不到供應元件
結果7月的時候跌得稀巴爛
可是電源的部分
其實是一直在跌代
一直在升級的
從過去啊
像這個過去伺服器的一邊
1.1到3kW
然後到近期的這個
5.5到12kW
大部分就5.5到12kW
然後呢
到了
接著要400到800伏
你們想一下裡面的這些銅線
這麼粗一根嗎
那個廠商會破廠
因為那個價格很高
所以我們必須要把這個電壓提高
800伏是不得不
有些人會擔憂說
這個800伏可能沒有會延後
我想跟大家講
比大家想的樂觀
有些人說要到2028
我覺得2027就會開始
有佔比會提升了
然後再來到未來就是 SST 固態變壓
固態變壓器
那除了它以外
在櫃子裡面或櫃子外面
也會搭配一些BBU
所以BBU最近
老實說也沒什麼表現
但是這個有人說BBU不是標配
不是百分之百用
我確定不是百分之百
可是它的比重會越來越提升
從過去的10%
一直到50%到60%以上
那過去的機期很低
它的價格從720塊
到未來是24000塊
你看看這成長有多大
那過去機器低
明年開始出貨
那明年呢
後年呢
大後年呢
成長就會很大
所以我今天提出來的數字
其實都還滿大的
這都不是我自己去key的啦
自己key我去key 369
那什麼
這是研究機構去看的
他們去統計
這就很VU持續在成長中
所以來到低機器的計算
今年低機器
那明年呢開始出貨
那明年我相信股價就會有所反應
好 整條電力供應鏈
感覺上我們台廠應該是很佔便宜
電源供應器也很多家
BBU也很多家在做
但是也是同樣的問題
就是在股價上面
對 好像市場的共識沒有辦法非常凝聚
對
這裡面就很多廠商
至於是這些人讓他們共識沒有凝聚
例如說
我最常講 ASKY
對 ASKY
不會漲就是不會漲
然后台达店前一阵子
落难成什么样子
没错
对
那我们就怪他
不要怪我们
没有啦
就是公司
没有其实是跟
我觉得好像台达店的董事长
是郑平郑董事长
是
他其实在法说会里面
他的回应都是比较平稳老实的
比如说他就说
我们毛利率
我们没有看那么高啦
毛利率看到什么38 39
35就OK啦
我们会好好做好
配合客户之类的
的确出来就是35不近
這個它意思我覺得這種誠實
總比你一直過度一直在講一直在講
然後呢
可是呢
這個公司交出來成績單卻不如預期
那可以看到
它把資本支出也提高到700億
代表說
實際上公司是很穩健的
在接未來的訂單
在準備未來的訂單
我們看到它是被評為
Great to Chip
就是從電網一直到
Chip 就是晶片的部分
最完整
甚至還預估
雖然剛才那個市值整個是成長對不對
需求整個成長
他佔有率居然是成長
很多都是市場價值增加
可是我佔有率會越少
他不是 他增加所以我覺得看到二六年四十一塊二七年六十三塊我這邊沒有寫二八年我寫在這邊是哇 其實你要讓他有一點時間
所以買的人請看二零二八
這中間都不要來找我
沒有
有修正就是很好的機會嗎
真的啊
沒有修正怎麼買呢 對不對
再來光寶的部分其實也表現很好
過去因為台打電
他本益比相對比較高
但光寶的本益比相對就比較低了
所以兩個就有點拉近
现在两个拉到算是一个比较合理
那就是大家可以介入的一个机会嘛
对不对
然后另外
除了HBDC
我们听到厂听到光宝啊
台大
也可以听到像康书嘛
康书圈年目标也希望能够达到30%
也有推出这1MW的这个HBDC
那主要它还是跟这个Bloom Energy
BE合作啦
所以BE概念股
它想到就高丽啊
它想到就康书啊
所以也可以留意
两样琴耶
嗯
高丽唱高
康书躺在地上
今天就漲停對不對
然後其他像計電器就比較少人講
我覺得可以留意一下計電器
而relate的部分
它主要就是負責這個保護
做高電流高耐壓的部分是保護
所以未來這個傳統的relate
轉型做這個AIDC的relate
它的成長看得出來很明顯
可以留意一下
其他就是BVU的部分
新勝利 順達 ASKY
我覺得是我比較注意的
這三個BVU的股票
但是大廠就 ASKY
大家就覺得這股價沒意思
順達跟新順利相對比較活潑
所以台達電回神還有戲嗎
我是覺得這是今天最新的KBOM
就是覺得這個
高點在這呢 還有戲吧
我覺得有機會啦
這個外資也是給它一個比較高的評價
近期啦
那他們也是看到比較遠一點點
如果你看很短線的話
的確股價短線很難預測
這好像穩造那個艾倫啦
那可是如果看比較
還不錯
短線也不錯
那場景我也覺得不錯
兩隻腳打好了
然後另外順達的部分
他這時候有這個外資發報告
就變得很活潑
活潑兩天就沒有了
可是經過這個整理完畢之後
我反而覺得
只要基本面沒有變的話
未來的這個題材也沒變
那訂單也在那邊的情況下
反而呢
這個
套用艾倫有時候
三角修煉
有看節目啦
然後呢
這種情況下
滿不離
這個稍微有一點動能之後
然後我們就來觀察看看好不好
好這個是在BBU的部分
還有電源供應器
其實台大電是很多元的啦
是
還有誰呢
最後總點名
終於
因為超過時間有點多
我就講一下
那除了這裡外
功率元件
對
這個今天禮拜二
禮拜二
我們有看到這個媒體也有在提說
像國外的廠商
國外大廠
像這個安西米他們
他們也在醞釀
10月10號雙十國慶
慶祝台灣去漲價
可是安西米漲價不是今天的效果
對不對
其實一直以來都有
他們有些廠商已經自己在漲價了
已經在漲價
那整個這個電源的需求技術提升
然後它的這個伏特數增加
對於功率元件要求其實是更高的
它這個耐壓程度
其實真的在做開關是誰你知道嗎
就是功率元件
就是要開關開關
不管是二極體還是 MOSFET
功率的是叫 Power MOSFET
都是他們在做工的
他們做工很辛苦
那很辛苦呢
股價我覺得近期
也蠻辛苦的
但是至少
我覺得它心跳的聲還蠻大聲的
就是有些呢
有些還蠻活潑的
3.50 跟你跳一下
到7.8%掌停
但是整體來說還在整理
那譬如說像強茂是整個比較
這個規模比較大一點
然後在 AI 跟車用三軌並進
那今年 AI 的營收目標也會到 15%
我覺得這裡面呢
就是最活潑成長最兇猛
有些就是投資人比較喜歡
就是那種成長很猛的
過去他的 AI 佔比很少
可是現在佔比就忽然間變高了
年增 114% 的營收
然後累增 91%
然後從 13% 的佔比變成 47% 的佔比
那 PowerMOSFET 佔 6 成
那未來也是譬如這個碳化系嘛
HBDC
所以如果你喜歡猛
猛爆性的
你希望這種就是
業績看起來高成長
有爆發性的
那你可以留意一下它
那另外
最正值是大封測時代
我前幾天也有看
所以大封測時代的情況下
那這個功率圓界有沒有封測
有 傑敏
這個傑敏也是一樣
它這個封裝測試代工廠
可是股價你看它的本益比相對
你看如果說今年
有機會賺9到10塊
股價是不是相對便宜啊
主要是拉回有疑慮啦
就是說它產能都在什麼
核肥啊
然後這些地方
那地緣風險政治的比較高一點點
可是人家的訂單
人家的獲利是擺在眼前的
還是有機會反應啦
可以留意一下
如果你覺得你也想要風車
想要肥肥比低一點的
可以考慮一下
最後呢
主要說明
強茂跟你剛剛講的
暴衝型的廣紅科
哦對
那因為強茂是整體來講的話
就是比較四比八穩
有規模
有這個 cash cow
Cash cow
就是像這個車用的部分
它在貢獻
所以整體來講是四比八穩
沒什麼問題
那近期也是一樣
這個畫線有點遠
我要稍微畫一下
持續墊高
然後墊高
站回所有均線
那當然前面這邊看起來
跌得比較快
這個套牢
可能冤魂重重
不過我們就觀察它一下
然後再來呢
是廣紅科的部分
也是一樣
這個
它怎麼股價沒暴衝啊
營收暴衝比較不安逸
欸 這邊有暴衝過一次喔
這邊有暴衝過一次喔
這邊的話就是剛剛講
六月的時候說什麼
市場上買不到功率元件
對
瞬間大家都買到了
對 大家買到了
我看下一頁
沒有了
有下一頁啊
沒有了沒有了
欸 還真的還有下一頁
對
你就知道你準備了多少東西吧
還好
但他們都躺在這而已
所以大家是很有時間
在台股創新高的時候
找到潛力低估的
是 那就有我剛才提到的嘛
它又有中國製造的疑慮嘛
但是本一比相對比較低一點點
今年獲利是比較穩健一些
股價也在這邊
那左側交易的人
自己去找機會找買點
那右側交易的人
就等他站回去
是
好 所以今天因為台股創新高
Vic帶來了
明明大家都在歡聲鼓舞
可是他們卻相對被低估的
所以非常謝謝Vic
因為我們需要了解產業的發展
你是給我們一個信心
這個產業的發展是沒有問題的
只是現在市場的資金
需要你去一個共識
沒有錯
好 如果他們回來的話
不要又變成買不到買不到買不到
希望能夠買不到
對啊 可是為什麼那時候市場會有這些傳言啊
就在漲的時候就會